75 millions d'euros d'investissements
pour réaliser ce centre commercial
tourné vers l'écologie c'est 10 % de
plus que pour une version classique et
15 ans d'amortissement nécessaire avec
le plus grand mur végétal du monde
les jardins et un parking ouvert
l'extension d'alpha parcs et aux
clayes-sous-bois mise sur une clientèle
familiale l'immobilier commercial
pendant des années c'était d'aider des
boîtes à chaussures en bardage pourri
qui défiguraient les entrées de ville
nous avons nous décidé d'investir dans
le développement durable nous avons
décidé d'investir dans la qualité car
nous pensons que les clients à l'époque
du commerce électronique vous continuez
à venir dans des centres commerciaux
mais dans lequel ils vont trouver un
plaisir qu'un plaisir de se promener un
plaisir d'aller faire du loisir une aire
de pique nique des restaurants et des
activités de bowling et de karting sont
proposés face à une concurrence féroce
le choix du développement durable et du
loisir s'est imposé il faut savoir
innover en permanence pour apporter aux
clients basse qu'il souhaite uscis qui
ne sait pas encore qu'il souhaite en
fait les premiers clients étaient
attendus mercredi matin
accueillis par des salariés recrutés le
plus souvent localement
au total 700 emplois avec le lave la
première phase d'alpha parcs qui sont
ils et qui leur étaient destinés en
priorité
bien sûr les siens puisque donc nous
avons même organisé des recrutements à
l'intérieur de la ville tout près d'ici
un autre centre commercial est en train
de sortir de terre
positionné sur la houlette de l'ups il
devrait permettre la création d'une
centaine d'emplois